[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
hey hey
we just started Jonathan
hi hello and welcome back to the break
room our daily live show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news you need
to know and yes it's a boys day here at
the break room Jess's advice to me when
I called her on the phone begging her to
be on the show today was just be more
feminine
that all the time coming up on the show
today Manny just think so finds a good
place in the galaxy far far away we've
got a new thirsty thespian to kill the
graphic National and we gotta we're
we're hearing something about Echo oh
Echo we're hearing something about Echo
we're hearing something about that there
you go uh I got lots of wonderful guests
on the show today I'm Brandon who cares
Jessica's not here because she's working
very hard on her she-hole
but across the table from me and across
my heart is John Cox hope to die that's
right
oh my God Cross Your Heart
yeah
no that's it I thought you had more
that's it uh next to John uh we got Tom
Michaelson say hello Tom hey yo how's it
going fam uh thanks for having me back
ready for this all boys
all right in that case let's get this
show on the road I don't give a crap
about it
ladies and gentlemen oh hello everyone
thanks for having me I can't wait for
the show today
there we go there we go uh uh today for
our chat Redemption because everyone
hates me we're gonna eat spicy things
yeah it's spicy Thursday it's spicy
Thursday with our spicy tip we better
need a better name
for spicy Thursday call him uh uh we're
taking for every hundred dollars in
super chats that we raised today we'll
eat something spicy yes uh Tommy's
written some numbers very sort of
looking like a zodiac
yeah
the number one associate to how much of
the spices
it's a very existential Redemption the
markers smell like genitals I apologize
to this part of the conversation
oh boy yeah we need a lady back on this
trip
Thursday absolutely not
um but yeah we're gonna be talking
She-Hulk episode five on this show today
so yeah if you haven't caught up make
sure you do come back to this video if
you're wondering why we spelled Avengers
wrong yeah if you're like watch the
episode and they're like oh these idiots
spelled Adventures wrong we got you yeah
I haven't seen Seahawk yet yeah you
haven't seen now you're the fool I think
the play is the thing where in will
catch the conscience of the Kings stop
being a nerd a little handle for you all
but before we get to that let's get to
some headlines hey
let's get to the headlines hey I already
said it well you know what let's get to
the headlines can we get one from Tom
hey let's get to the headlines guys
let's do it hey variety is reporting
that Manny Jacinto if you're familiar
with the good place has been cast in the
upcoming Disney plus series the actual
is
so beautiful that's right because he was
one of the villagers yeah yeah I don't
know what that is but uh
yeah uh a variety is heard from sources
that Jacinto uh is joining a previously
announced series led by
um I'm in love why am I doing some
headlines today
in the series as well as cast members
Jody Turner Smith and Lee jong-jae yeah
lots of casting news about it yeah it
sounds like they're gonna settle down we
don't want anything spicy come on be
cool I would love an all ladies uh uh
break room that sounds like a lot of fun
uh hey hey the procedural move we left
procedure Disney has removed Patty
Jenkins Road squadron from its release
schedule don't worry Star Wars movie
fans we still have movies being produced
by Kevin feige uh potential Ryan Johnson
type of thing we've got taikaway titties
movie and we've got Skeleton Crew
they're not done with movies there's
rumors about a Mandalorian movie
happening too but on this Disney release
day Shuffle they also moved an Untitled
Marvel film from February 16 2024 that
was sort of going to be a late phase
Five movie they've moved that movie to
September 6th 2024 which is going to
come out between the Thunderbolts and
Fantastic Four a lot of people were
thinking that was Deadpool 3.
um it won't be a Spider-Man film because
Sony sets the release dates on those we
don't know what it is it would be crazy
if Deadpool sews the whole face hey it's
a Multiverse story right yeah
it would just also be no if he's been
like Captain Marvel but like yeah you
need to to win the whole thing and then
it turned out uh we we didn't need to
watch that movie in order to enjoy end
games I'm not I'm not upset
uh I went to the premiere of that movie
it was a lot of fun uh Keke Palmer has
responded to some fast and uh to some
fan casting of her as rose
on Tick Tock were fan casting her as
Rogue uh and she sent out this little
tweet
um saying call my agent what does it say
come on agents
you gotta like tag your agent I think
that's right right agents on Twitter
uh maybe she's at a boutique
this way I'm sure other people have
gotten cast in the MCU by just asking
yeah just at Kevin feige like hey movie
please yeah next headline
Rashida sheets uh why why am I doing
this
sure yeah from south side has joined the
cast of Marvel Studios Disney plus
Series ironheart in an undisclosed role
by a deadline why do they keep doing
this to us undisclosed role disclose the
role if they disclose the role it ruins
it right we have to speculate do you
remember Tommy at D20 they were saying
they're still shooting iron Hearts I
believe yeah all the footage they showed
which I had like felt very early right
well it did but it also had some VFX
like very complete VFX done on it but
they're still shooting this show so it's
very interesting these are just
trickling out because they want this
show to be in the in the headlines news
cycle if we can see any of these people
on black panther wakanda forever I don't
know it's funny because a lot of these
uh a lot of the times I think they just
I think they're they're their play
Marvel is just to have it be undisclosed
every world because sometimes I you know
they'll cast somebody be like ooh
undisclosed and the move will come out
and be like oh you're just a small side
agent yeah it didn't really matter yeah
uh next headline a lock with Cox has
revealed uh some of the first plot
details for echo in an interview with
phase zero at d23 uh over the weekend uh
can we play that clip now the last time
we saw you in the MCU ilaqua Echo shot
Kingpin in the face now I want to hear
what does that mean for where we find
you in this series picks up
okay so all I can say is that Maya's
actions are leading her to Oklahoma
to reconnect with her indigenous roots
and find the definition of family and
Community but we don't know about
Kingpin yet I don't really know can't
really say anything
she goes on she goes on to make a little
bit of a flub in that she gives off some
information she says she goes back to
her uh she goes back to her family in
Oklahoma to connect with her indigenous
roots and that leads her to finding out
about her powers and then she's like oh
yeah
um so we saw some descriptions of
footage at d23 yeah
and said you thought her hands looked
like they were yeah he looks at her
hands it looks like they're going but
there's also going to be a lot of kind
of magical realism in this show in that
it's gonna go through generations we're
gonna see like flashbacks to her her
ancestors yeah things like that and it
it looks like they're presenting this
idea of like a Female warrior of the
tribe that has either distinguishing
tattoos or symbols uh and in that
trailer too we see like an elder who
makes uh one of her prosthetic legs but
puts like that sun symbol that we've
seen on her jacket a tattoo on her
father he says something about it being
like a source of power or a symbol of
power that's interesting that makes a
lot of sense especially since then the
first lines with echo in it they're
talking about dragons and magic and in
the comics right now um or I don't know
I think she still is uh Echo becomes a
new host of The Phoenix Force so I
wonder if there's a connection it seems
like they're probably not connected a
lot of people are speculating Phoenix
Force but this seems like it's probably
coming from her family yeah but who
knows if they're gonna like present the
if who knows how they'll do the Phoenix
force in the MCU out of order in terms
of like Gene getting it first type of a
thing or have it be part of her family's
magic that's connected to yeah
run it again he's a charm yeah like an
idea that like the Phoenix force is
something that existed on Earth and like
in the MCU it comes from Earth it
becomes a problem for the rest of the
Galaxy the idea that Earth is always the
problem in the MCU there's too much too
much bad stuff going on there I think
it'd be a lot of fun but I'm excited to
see the show and what the sense I got
from Kevin feige as he talked about like
iron heart with the idea of like
technology versus magic yes I think that
we'll see more and more of that uh in
this these phases they're on a collision
course right like we've had a lot of
magic recently like the Rings right the
10 rings are both technology and Magic
sure uh Oliver Thor's hammer yeah yeah
mjolnir yeah uh Hey next headline
I'm so sorry
hey you next time after announcing the
Avengers King Dynasty at this year's
Comic-Con Marvel Studios have found the
writer who will pen this highly
anticipated flick
we missed the story yesterday I
apologize it came in it was a little too
late a little too late deadlines
reporting that Jeff loveness uh writer
on Rick and Morty but now recently uh
wrote Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
is going to be writing Kang Dynasty for
Marvel I want to talk about this a
little bit before we get to our main
discussion today uh Daniel Destin is
going to be directing directed The Ten
Rings uh in the legend of ten rings
uh also going to be directing the Shang
Chi sequel
um but it is interesting to see Marvel
sort of graduating people from projects
to bigger projects
there are some rumors we don't usually
talk about rumors on this channel
there's some rumors
that Ryan might be the person that
they're trying to get to direct secrets
producers
coming out um but I think he has an
overall deal with Marvel
um but it's interesting right they took
um the writer from Loki Mike Waldron and
loved what he did on Loki and sort of
graduated him to Doctor Strange the
Multiverse of Madness yeah do you think
this like leads any Credence to the fact
that maybe Marvel just loves quantumania
a lot and uh
it's a Kang show but you guys have seen
footage now from quantumania the vibe
around it definitely feels like they're
like we got something great here cool we
all know what like we got to get this
out to the man because they're making it
kind of a concerted effort to be like
this is an Ant-Man movie but it's also a
MCU movie like it's it's not just a
standalone franchise for Ant-Man it is
important to the MCU so I I feel like
with all the effort they're putting into
that they must know they're honest I'm
getting Vibes almost like a Captain
America Civil War which that was Captain
America three right but it was such uh
you know like it was I was a Nexus for
all these things that are going to
explode from the MCU and that's that's
the vibe I'm getting I haven't even seen
them well edit Comic-Con Kevin feige did
uh lump this film in when he was talking
about Marvel team-up films he sort of
mentioned Doctor Strange yeah he
mentioned a couple other films and and
called them Tina Doctor Strange the
Multiverse Madness Wanda Dr Strange
I wasn't arguing with you I was just
thinking well I'm just saying they he he
referred to this as a team up now we we
only know right that uh the regular
Ant-Man cast is going to be in it plus
Cassie and Bill Murray Bill Murray is
going to be in the film uh and then
Modoc and doom but we don't know of any
people from you know existing MCU
properties that are going to join
um you didn't see any of that in in new
footage because so people are saying
like maybe some kind of TVA Loki might
show up but I think that's just because
Kang is going to be in the film
um but it'll be interesting to see if or
who is going to be in that movie
yeah I I think you're on the right track
though I think you know loveness is
writing of Kang might have impressed
them enough to be like hey why don't you
kind of keep telling this story we like
what you're setting up here and yeah I
did get the scent that like the first
half or the first third of that movie
will feel like an Ant-Man movie The more
comedy side you know a little more
light-hearted but then it's probably
gonna get heavy and serious and like
really start to break apart which will
be exciting if you guys before maybe
that's the team
[Music]
no I think the fantastic one just set it
in the channel
Fantastic Four is just gonna be four
separate stories that have nothing to do
with each other
Fantastic Four stories
uh if you could have another good place
actor in Star Wars who would it be
Kristen Bell I'd love to see Kristen
Bell take on a come on yeah
I'll just say dazzler you know she can
sing she's uh probably can roller skate
really well I think Eric had pitched Ted
someone in the slack today pitched Ted
Danson is doom and I mean that's not
Star Wars obviously but that would be
fun yeah yeah I know he's just he's
getting so old I love him but he's like
protect him protect him dancing uh do
you think Echo will forgive Kingpin 77
said no
no
I think it depends on the food
though she went boom I forgive you
you know what
we'll get into forgiven yeah you're
right you need something much worse yeah
it's the adage if you shoot a man in the
heart you kill him immediately shoot a
man in the face friend for life exactly
my favorite adage and do you think we'll
get a Rick and Morty reference in either
of loveness's MCU films 65 said yes I'm
worried that these sleeper Rick and
Morty writers are now
planted in the NCAA
hey maybe Bill Murray's gonna play a
Rick
I'm afraid I'm a friend
from the inside yeah exactly you know
there was a there was a knock on
Avengers or the very first episode
yeah of uh Rick and Morty this season
yeah
we haven't gotten the Rick and Morty
reference in She-Hulk yet we have not we
didn't get one in Loki we did not get
one in uh Multiverse of Madness I I
don't know maybe he was like do it right
away yeah they do it right away then
they'll get they'll get caught you've
got
does it count if the Citadel of Ricks
was based off of the Illuminati and then
we got the Illuminati in a Waldron I
think it counts I think it counts uh
knickknacks sent in a super jet saying
love you guys but I think we need an all
ladies break room next yeah I don't
think anyone's arguing with that yeah
hey if you're a lady out there calling
uh
Robin suggesting Thirsty Thursdays or
Thursdays Thursdays Thursdays
thirsty for spicing new Masters saying
you would call it spicy thespians well
Tommy's an actor Tom's an actor I don't
know about him
I act like a piece of [ __ ]
I know Chicago once oh look at this guy
there you go
uh uh match 143 saying Anna wear puppy
heart eyes
yesterday's show oh
uh you know what else was pretty spicy
uh hitting that like button oh but what
else was hit it what else was uh spicy I
thought was last night's episode of
She-Hulk
um I love this reveal of like a
superhero costume maker it's so mean so
vicious I love that actor I forget his
name he's on the flight attendant
probably the best thing about that show
uh but this reveal that there's a
there's a haberdasher for the
superheroes right and he's successful
enough that he is he has like the secret
office he's got a lot of materials he's
working with so it seems like there's
enough like B level and C Level either
enhanced or superhumans at this point to
keep this guy going now he could be he
could be existing on like the idea that
he works for superheroes but he seems
pretty not blessed to be in the presence
yeah like it was not very shocking for
him and also you know he has an
exclusive Heir about him right so he
must have a client list that's long
enough to she hasn't got an Avenger yet
hasn't gotten an Avenger yet got pretty
close walking out the door when she
walked in wasn't that frog or LeapFrog
leaving I think the back of him with the
uh
she's getting close that's what I'm
saying you saw him got that helmet for a
DD I just think it's really great that
you know this whole time they've had to
really kind of I I feel like go out of
their way to explain how these super
costumes get here like right you know AO
comes with this briefcase to Sam
Wilson's been like by the way we made
this for you it is from wakanda and now
that Tony's gone and no one can just he
can't just whip out a suit for you like
he did for Spider-Man it makes sense to
kind of have a hub now where they can
just say remember that guy he made the
suit now let's move on because otherwise
they would have to explain while
Jennifer Walters in this stretchy purple
thing why why it makes sense now this
was like a very uh Edna Mode from
Incredibles yes joke that's being done
but like uh the the fashionista kind of
uh hot Couture uh superhero suit maker
because in in the dead of what Netflix
show he has his boy in New York uh
Gladiator yes
or something Peter
if you're a daredevil
costumer Colin he is the Gladiator I
remember that yeah he's in jail he was a
job and he was also like working out of
a garage and very underground this is
like much more mainstream which is
interesting uh and I also but still
underground right they had to go to a
bulb attack and then they had to be
shown a bunch of Avengers merchandise
but that's that's also building up the
exclusivity of them right if it's
difficult to get into he this guy
doesn't need influencers coming in off
the street filming content in his Studio
he's got to have some layer of
protection so question did did Matt
Murdoch go and hire this guy Daredevil
go higher because that was my other one
he would walk in and be like I'm just
looking for this week's no really what I
really want is a suit or make my friend
uh suit my clients thank you
um
thank you thank you all right Melvin
part of the Gladiator uh two questions I
love what you're bringing about
Daredevil
they're still saying Avengers right now
is is she an Avenger Avenger Avenger
Avengers
public is still using Avenger
terminology at this point we are post
shangshi so we're post uh we're post the
the guy coming out of the ground this
Celestial coming out of the ground
the snap uh the blip the blippening
whatever you want to call it we've this
debate about whether or not the the
events of uh no way home have happened
oh right I like to think they happen I
have to think that they are they've
happened I don't think they have
happened yet I will have the argument
with you
right but Wong wouldn't remember that's
what I'm saying he would know this about
maybe someone but they also established
sorry I'm derailing no you're right
about that they established in no way
home that they do the memory white spell
all the time and Wong had done it before
yes Christmas party I'm saying that then
could just be like I'm not doing it
everywhere I'll fight you
but we also as we talked about on this
show on Tuesday Kevin feige brought up
the idea that there are no Avengers
right now but that's also like the
government maybe isn't making it very
clear though you get the doctor strange
to watch I think we'll get you back in
The Lunchbox so they're still
merchandising there's people out there
yeah
yeah there's people you're rich these
mugs
can't get this mug though can't get this
mug
okay so the inventors the public at
least thinks there is an Avengers
organization
we're being lied to it's what they call
security theater folks like money it's
not real it's not real uh it's just ones
and zeros in your bank account nothing's
real
um Daredevil I'll talk about Daredevil
so this kind of makes sense to me
because I was wondering before how does
Matt Murdock come to LA right the
Daredevil because
I didn't even think of that if he's
going through TSA if he's flying
commercial which I assume Matt Murdock's
fine commercial you can't check your
costumes into the yeah but he's not got
a private play he doesn't work for a big
he mailed it but even mailing it is
risky you're gonna lose your suit in the
mail and you don't think the post office
is going through your packages you don't
think the UPS guys checking stuff he can
just just for Daredevil's sake if he
gets lost all he needs is some black
hoodie and bandanas and now we're back
to the background he doesn't know what
his costume looks like why should we
care right which is why I think he's
negative the yellow on there I think he
went in there with the red one saying
hey I'm Daredevil okay
can you get me a new
job advice to L.A with his yellow nails
it ahead of time okay I don't believe
that either I think that's too racy but
I do like the idea of him
calling a guy in LA to make him a suit
yeah so he doesn't have to risk losing
his suit in the mail or traveling with
it I think that's very well but also you
could you could do this right we saw in
Multiverse of Madness when Dr Strange
was walking around in Earth 838 that
people were like you [ __ ] stole that
thing didn't you uh he could just walk
around and be like I'm a daredevil
impersonator came from Avengers
especially a guy like Daredevil you run
a risk with having this costumer who is
well known enough that the you know the
drip hookup knows how to fight the Boba
guy knows yeah the drip broker the drip
The Joker my apologies uh that's a pug
out there uh you would think a bad guy
could find this guy too it'd be like hey
what are the weaknesses to Daredevil
suit like what are you know this is uh
Rogue one all over again this guy could
be putting deficiencies inside of these
suits
but that's a good question do you think
he's working both sides he's like I
think yeah yeah he doesn't see good and
bad
baby clients uh it's also why I think
Sam Wilson uh Captain America needs to
get rid of his suit immediately I agree
because they're bugging it the what
comments have shown that they building
[Laughter]
tongue torture Thursday I hate the sound
of that and Bucky Barnes ATL always keep
it in Gucci to Mucho we think our super
Chatters out there again if we had 100
super chat we'll spin the wheel and eat
that number of spices jelly beans spicy
chips that quantity of spicy items we'll
also make time we drink another gallon
of water to keep him nice and liquefied
uh inside and out
um but yeah I my I guess like the
biggest thing we're asking here is like
with this guy who's building enough
suits do you think there is like a West
Coast Avengers is there enough question
here is there a group on the west coast
right now well I think they're just by
nature of uh you know if the
government's not running around yeah
you're thinking nothing Captain Marvel I
know she landed in L.A but she's not
from L.A but I was just gonna say what
if what if the next episode She-Hulk
goes to New York actually and somehow
the the guy's mailing Matt Murdoch suit
back to him I love this male idea just
don't just let me have you guys obsessed
with the man yeah I actually worked for
UPS uh on the side anyway but what if
what if they're going to New York and
that way it's not Matt Murdock trying to
get to L.A because I didn't think about
that I was like why is coming down
my big question is we have heard the
show is going to deal with the sokovia
chords in one way or another right you
have all these like small time enhanced
people popping up all over the place the
government has to do something about
that if they have this sokovic you know
still go in place right so you know I
don't know what what it's going to look
like but but we keep seeing these
low-level Fighters we know that there's
going to be this Emile Blonsky support
group coming in some episode hi Tommy
welcome back
um we built an obstacle question so uh
with that being said there is an
Avengers right like a c-list group of
Heroes for sure in Los Angeles or on the
west coast there's a west coast of
Honduras definitely happening I would
love to see them team up sounds like
something we should talk about later
I think he's maybe teasing some fun we
could have occasions mandatory
you mean my mind yeah you can get that
mug now right uh right uh at new
rockstarsmerch.com have a piece of the
break room in your very own break room
wherever that may be uh maybe I'll wash
my hands Sammy yes I I hope to Gotti
watches they're so soapy clean smell
like smell it for me John
um I said it's either piss or water uh
we also want to remind you that next
Tuesday will be our 100th episode uh
despite your best efforts they haven't
canceled us yet and we're still going
strong please don't tell Phil Molina
we're still on the email but we are
going to celebrate 100 episodes next
Tuesday so make sure you tune it out
we're gonna have a lot of fun on here go
ahead and hit that like button if you
haven't already and we also would like
to take a quick moment uh to share a
word from our sponsors I better help we
all want to take care of our brains and
keep them happy and healthy one good way
to do that is through therapy but maybe
you don't want to leave your house maybe
you're like I like my house I like my
desk I like my cat I like my poster
Billy Joel
thankfully our friends have better help
offer online Therapy Solutions I wasn't
sharing a personal experience there but
I will now my poster Billy Joel fell to
the floor today was it a ghoul was it a
goblin or was it just Jesus Christ
reminding me that the Piano Man
is active and out there he lost weight
during the pandemic oh I gained weight
which is why better help has been
helpful for me like I said before better
help is online therapy so you can do
whatever you feel uh you know wherever
where you feel most comfortable and they
offer video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions so you don't have
to see anyone on camera if you don't
want to you just put that camera off
put your sunglasses on inside no one's
judging you it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy
and this is the part I really actually
will be serious for one moment it is
really nice our listeners get 10 off the
first month at betterhelp.com break room
so use the code break room 10 off guys
if you're struggling I'm look at me I'm
a mess
if you're struggling go to Better Health
what do you got to lose Google talk to
somebody share that share with somebody
God knows don't DM me
in my in my uh uh unfollowed Instagram I
can't help you
better help Ken or maybe I will I don't
know reach out to me that's better
health better halp.com break room I love
you get in my DMs too but go to Better
Health take care of yourself
what what oh oh that's what could hear
you I guess even though you know you
said it right to a shirt
[Laughter]
[Applause]
for mandatory fun
the segment so successful Dash was
pressing that graphic Button as much
yeah here's the the name there's a
chance to actually left hours ago
this thing is on a swivel I'm sorry it's
my fault it's not your fault we're
having fun all right listen we all saw
the Boba bootleg merch on She-Hulk and I
liked it as a man who used to buy effing
go nuts in Dunkin Donuts
and middle fingers towards the Duke Blue
Devil shirts every chance I could get
Nike that just said just did it with a
satisfied smiley face listen I bought
all the bootleg merch I could as a boy
we saw someone She-Hulk yesterday we saw
the Avengers The Avengers
Avengers
yeah it's a who's he it's a wussy it's
very dust okay that's a Wolf of Wall
Street
here's what I thought boys
my guys
ASMR
Buffalo
hot wings sauce uh let's make up our own
bootleg merch I'll go first oh it's all
right let's do it actually I can't be
here for this moment oh no oh so sorry
guys I'm actually getting this is so
Random
Dr Shabazz and Dr nasty might you
trusted Physicians Shabazz is actually
my attorney but he also works he's a
Juris doctor
they got a hold of some lemur tendons
okay and they're gonna put him in my
back okay so I gotta go but there's
someone else to get a little Nimble okay
nice so I want to see your guys best
bootleg merch okay okay all right well I
don't have any merch uh unfortunately
but I do have this shirt and so uh if I
were a bootleg Avenger I'd probably be
Captain America all right Captain land
of the free home of the brave with red
white and blue coming through our veins
you don't believe me I asked about Mima
the blue of her Miracles she real blue
like an avatar all right nowhere else
but murka can you get uh like a jug of
mayo and a bazooka that'll blow your ass
off that's right Walmart we made that
too so in America and Captain America is
I'm the one who's really going to hold
it down you think Steve Rogers got
America's ass I can fit America on my
ass all right that that's that's what
it's like being the real Captain America
why don't you shut your damn mouth oh my
God
just shut up
shut up team Michael Bechtel hey man
about town fashionista producer you
might have covered your mind team
Michael convicted to make sure they can
hear you can you hear me hot sauce hey
Buffalo Bills this is my bird Perseus
and we would like to introduce our
product
it's not Hawkeye everyone Clint Barton
hit the trash it's Crow's nose you need
accuracy you don't use your eyes anymore
user
sniffer oh you smell it sniff it out
Precision accuracy everybody's got a
stink and we're out there to find it
I gotta go
well he's got to go find it everybody do
crows have nose crows have six noses
they're like earthworms they have five
Hearts gigantical factories what's your
noses he's saying this as he walks very
far away I've gotta go
um I have um I have a friend a friend
here who are you uh I'm I'm squished
um uh the counterpart in the comics to
Blade
bling
so in this version of the avongers
there's a there's not a blade there's
yes I tried to uh I tried to stop any
sort of encounter I can with uh
I tried to uh give people what they're
missing from their life which is usually
a friend or a stuffed animal to rip into
shreds
all I'm thinking right now is the uh
Psychopaths and our YouTube uh that ask
for us to timestamp this stuff every day
and I'm like I'm hoping time stamps yeah
we're gonna do that for you you guys
don't deserve time Stan
no not you
was your mom yeah uh bitten by uh maybe
a sponge of the night or a radioactive
sponge
because she was in a conversation and
was receiving a SpongeBob
unfortunately she was bit I hate this
happened it had teeth uh I think I think
foam was a stronger you you have all the
powers of of a squishy phone but none of
their weaknesses it's not foam it's
strong yeah
it's definitely not blade
I had a better pitch in time
of course you're familiar with the
goddess Thunder himself Thor okay but uh
oh yeah uh this cat here okay oh [ __ ]
he's he's not Thor all right he's not
Thor he's thawing
up from from Asgard
Gotta Wear my uh glass Guardian jewelry
here
thong is the God of Thunder from Down
Under you know give you those thunderous
thighs making those Thunder ass clusters
do you have to uh have any special
powers to lift the thong yeah yeah
You Gotta Be You gotta be worthy of
wearing a thought okay if you don't got
a dump in your trunk you can't lift the
thong you know what I'm talking about
yeah get it yeah you were the one who
empowered Cisco to write that song and
make it a stallion at the end of this
episode of She-Hulk they worship songs
yeah okay amazing they played a thong
every night he prayed at home
yeah I didn't know I could do it but I'm
gonna do it tonight
uh I don't I don't like that we're
getting a who had the best Avengers well
we've got way too much
listen we've got plenty of time to talk
about Android but we won't
Tommy we should talk about it we should
talk about Andor I've now seen three
episodes one and uh your boy got to
interview the cast yesterday I can't
wait for those videos to come out
because I got in there with them you
know I made it personal that's right and
now this will be um is your interview
gonna be on what can lead I hope not I
hope it's on the break room oh wow
wow baby bro Wookie leaks that's my side
job okay I like that I heard you got a
date after uh uh yeah me and Fiona Shaw
are actually an item oh okay that's
incredible that's the fishing stuff I
hope she's watching she promised you
it's kind of part of being Tommy's girl
you got to watch and because the police
were carrying me out of the junket room
she was like I'll watch tomorrow baby
yeah you did break then you were not
invited it was a zoom jumper it could be
clear but you shut up live regardless
let me talk to him in person I gotta
make icon tell me Tommy swatted the uh
the zoom interview Diego Luna I'm the
original lunatic let me look you in the
eyes Luna means Moon
coming out next week which will be
coming around the channel we'll have uh
uh Wikileaks Returns on Wednesday and by
the way this show I'm sorry not not to
Hype it up this Show's freaking I'm so
excited
please hype it up I'm not you know I'm
not a show I don't care about Disney
yeah oh [ __ ] what the hell is happening
right now
you know I'm not gonna tell you to watch
something I don't believe in myself and
or who watch it once watch it twice
watch it chicken soup with brownies
it does it does look good so we'll have
we'll have uh Wikileaks come out that
day in the afternoon because we know you
guys need time to watch three episodes
uh Eric's breakdown will start coming
out on Wednesday we're going to come out
that day uh like we said Jessica's
working on the She-Hulk breakdown right
now we're also busy could the break room
survive tomorrow the break room will
survive they're tearing us apart
the program will survive it again you're
breaking my heart uh Aaron burkson the
arienberg apology sending area uh of a
Super Chat saying can we have an a force
team for the break room please at least
one day of the week though yeah bro bro
testosterone is okay but too much Miss
Marvel proves it Jessica proves it and
the Werewolf Corgi moment yesterday was
award comedy win do they get all
comedies for this
that was my idea okay they did my idea
yesterday while I was doing the work for
you guys I didn't even get the wolf out
what's happening to me
no oh no we don't have any of the audio
Keys ready
yeah
hey uh We've read a poem who had the
best defenders member Brandon won with a
Rousey bro bro
you think we would have noticed no you
think you would have noticed not sure
people have spoken Crow's nose hell's
nose man
um oh no hey thank you for watching the
break room today it's gonna be a little
bit more on on hinge uh tomorrow so come
back and join us yeah definitely join us
tomorrow Fridays are usually pretty
great around here and I'm sure it'll be
pretty nice tomorrow like we said our
100th episode is coming up next Tuesday
almost 100 episode Eve I can barely
sleep I've been hiding my Elf on the
Shelf yeah take the day off work you
know uh make sure you're you got plenty
of icing actually don't risk it quit
your job
always good always get fired so you can
collect
uh thank you to everyone for tuning in
today thank you all our super Chatters
presenting your super chats uh be sure
to join our Discord where you can submit
your Clips to the week uh we'll have a
clip of the week tomorrow I guarantee it
uh you can send in voicemails that we
will get to one of these days we love
the voicemail you're not the technology
we're working on the technology
ask us anything you want call me I'll
give you Brandon's number
tell me whenever you want uh and make
sure you tune in tomorrow for our Friday
show it'll be very exciting uh that's
another guarantee hit that like button
if you haven't already and subscribe God
join it and what's going on with you
guys you watch the show and you don't
subscribe gosh what are you some kind of
sicko you jump out of the plane with no
parachute subscribe to us you owe me I
do this for you guys you think I'm happy
doing this this is misery
you think I want to be 40 doing YouTube
you better subscribe you owe me this is
incredible stuff this is what happens
when we eat too many spicy things
submit exhibit a oh don't worry I'm
being arraigned on Monday I probably
won't be here Tuesday all right well
we'll see if Tommy likes it here next
week until then we'll see you tomorrow
right here on the break room
out of you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]